good morning relief nation today's
message is follow your passion over you
George Lucas everything I did I was
following something I really cared about
something I loved something I was
passionate about and I kept following
that passion whether it was cars whether
it was anthropology whether it was art
photography and eventually it led me to
my huge passion my real passion which
was making movies which combined all
those things and I realized that had I
gone on to get my degree in anthropology
I would have probably made
anthropological movies in New Guinea or
someplace and eventually been on
National Geographic and you know the
History Channel and been than making
features and I had done Star Wars just
the same if I'd gone the Arts Center and
become an illustrator I would have
probably started doing animation and
doing animated films and making animated
things and then ultimately I would have
gone on and been right where I was so no
matter which route I took because I
cared about all of them they all went to
the same place had I done what my father
had wished me to do which is to go into
these office equipment business with him
which I knew like wasn't what I do I
knew I hated that my life would have
been unpleasant and so I think it's very
important not to do what your peers
think you should do not do what your
parents think you should do or your
teachers but to do what you inside or
even your culture things but do what's
inside you so what do you think yeah I
think you should follow your passion
that's what I've done in my life
and it's changed my entire life yeah I
mean I mean this is something that yeah
I know you believe in strongly you know
to do the things you really love and
make a difference in the world with your
passions for those you've been a fancy
for channel this is an easy message for
me
right it's a constant theme through all
the videos that I'm doing if you want to
do something great yeah ask me something
that you can be great at and you have a
great love for it's not so much what
your knowledge that is right now or what
you're good at yet right now but if you
have a desire to learn something and you
want to get better it's insane the
progress that you can make and how
quickly you can get really really really
good and so I guess just maybe take a
little bit deeper I encourage you to not
hold yourself back because you feel like
you don't have the experience necessary
to be successful a lot of people think
oh really what I really really really
really want to write a book I really
really really really want to be a
consultant or whatever it is but I've
never done that before and the fact that
you've never done that before
holds you back from doing something that
you really want to learn and what's
there's a famous expression I have a
skill is like ignorant ignorant I'm fire
is better than experienced on Heights is
something like that's not quite that but
it's close it's just showing you that
there's a lot of smart people a lot of
people a lot of experience they don't
have the hustle in all the dry little
the passion the excitement anymore for
what they're doing and so you can easily
overtake them remin I pulled this around
the channel before but I did that at my
agency where I went from being the worst
to being the best practice example in a
couple of months but people had way more
experience because I put it in the
hustle because I was making multiple
videos a day when they were doing one a
week if that and so if you have the
passion for something don't let anything
else hold you back because you can learn
any skill that you need to be successful
you can't
passion you got to love that thing that
you do that makes you come alive and the
second you stop loving something have
the confidence and courage to jump to
something else that you are excited
about and makes you come alive I love
that because I do think a lot of people
don't even question sometimes they think
they love I think you think they're good
at this or they think they really want
to start a business but really if they
really thought about it is that really
what your passion is it really what
makes you come alive and you just put it
you know really question question
yourself and what really makes you come
alive and really is it makes you
passionate about it because that's
really what's going to drive success so
the question that they today is tell us
what your passion is write it down
because words make it real leave in the
comment below we're gonna join in the
discussion I like it thank you guys for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shots a vinspresso